[onscreen voices]
- [slurps]
MM-MM. MM-MM.
COME ON, MAN,
WHAT YOU DOIN', MAN?
THAT'S STUPID.
THAT'S STUPID, MAN,
DON'T DO THAT, MAN. COME ON.
- ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
DO NOT GO INTO
A CRANE SHOT RIGHT NOW!
YOU KIDDING ME?
- YEAH, MAN, I HEAR Y'ALL.
THIS MOVIE'S GOT
A INCONSISTENT VISUAL LANGUAGE!
- HALF THE TIME, THIS [bleep]
JUST SHOOTIN' ALL HAND-HELD
LIKE HE
A DOGMA FILMMAKER!
THAT'S FUNNY,
SINCE DOGMA
CLEARLY FORBIDS
TEMPORAL AND GEOGRAPHICAL
ALIENATION!
[sudden music strike]
- OH, I LOVED THAT SHOT
THE FIRST TIME.
WHEN IT WAS IN NOSFERATU!
- [laughs]
THAT'S RIGHT.
- I MEAN, THIS [bleep]
TRYIN' TO DO SOME HOMAGE
TO THE GERMAN EXPRESSIONISTS
OR SOME [bleep].
- IT'S A VISUAL
MEDIUM, MAN!
ENOUGH WITH THIS MY DINNER
WITH ANDRE BULL[bleep]!
- I MEAN, HAS THIS DUDE
EVEN HEARD OF MISE-EN-SCENE?
PUT SOME INFORMATION
UP IN THE FRAME, BITCH!
- OH, I GET IT. YEAH.
I'MA OVEREXPOSE THE FILM.
- MM-HMM, MM-HMM.
- GET AN ETHEREAL LOOK.
MAN, [bleep] THIS [bleep]!
- CAN WE JUST GO?
- HOLD ON, HONEY, THEY'RE
ACTUALLY MAKING GOOD POINTS.
[onscreen voices]
HEY, HAS THIS GUY WATCHED TOO
MUCH QUENTIN TARANTINO OR WHAT?
- SIR, WE'RE GONNA NEED YOU
TO LOWER YOUR VOICE.
TOO MUCH TALKING, OKAY?
THANK YOU.
- THANK YOU.